(whimsical music)
- These Santas are all
really kids at heart.
They like the fun and
laughter that comes with it,
and making people happy;
that's why we're here.
If you ask 'em why their Santa,
most of 'em will tell you
because they enjoyed being a child,
so they're going back to that.
They're reliving their childhood.
It's a wonderful thing.
(applause)
Welcome everyone to the Charles W. Howard
80th anniversary Santa Claus School.
(cheering)
♪ You better watch out ♪
♪ You better not cry ♪
♪ You better not put ♪
♪ I'm telling you why ♪
♪ Santa Claus ♪
♪ Is coming ♪
♪ To town ♪
(cheering)
- My name's Tom Valent.
I'm the Dean of the Charles W. Howard
Santa Claus School in Midland, Michigan.
This is the Harvard of Santa schools.
This is the oldest-running Santa
Claus school in the world.
It was started by Charlie Howard in 1937.
At Santa Claus school we learn everything
from beard keeping to personal hygiene.
- What we're gonna do, we're
gonna start with a base.
- [Tom] To toy making,
to what it feels like
to ride on the Polar Express.
(laughing merrily)
To flying the sleigh.
- I want us to not be afraid of dance.
- [Tom] Santa has to be healthy.
He's a healthy outdoorsman.
If you're not healthy,
you're gonna drift off,
you're not gonna pay attention.
It's very important to
have all the skills you can
to be a great Santa, because the child
is gonna remember this visit
for the rest of your life.
- Ho ho ho!
Merry Christmas!
- [Tom] When Charlie had this school,
he had three or four students,
in good years, maybe 15 students.
This year, we have 214.
It just grows.
We have Santa's of course
from almost every state
in the United States.
We have around 20 Santas from Canada.
We have three Santas from Denmark,
one from Norway, and one from Germany.
There's a real sense of
camaraderie in this school.
It's like this large Santa
family coming together.
They share stories, they
learn from each other.
We want to be Santas to make people happy.
Well when we get together
we're making each other happy.
I love it!
Once they leave this school,
I hope that each and every
Santa and Mrs. Claus
goes out and spreads
the spirit of Christmas,
spreads the love and joy that
we have here at this school,
and passes it on to all
the little children,
and all the families.
When you give joy, you
get it back two-fold.
(hollering)